[Musique]
bonjour à tous et très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle saison de
politique à table sur LCP toujours
autour d'un invité d'un plat et d'un
dessert nous sommes ensemble pendant 1
heure et pour bien démarré cette année
gastronomique et bien nous recevons un
invité exceptionnel Yve kandbord bonjour
bonjour bonjourjour kandborne avec moi
pour présenter cette émission bien sûr
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour
jean-pierreonjour Brigit alors rcand
deborde vous êtes chef cuisinier pionné
de la bistronomie mibistro m gastro vous
vous avez inspiré toute une génération
de jeunes chefs avec la régalade puis
avec le comptoir du relais à
Saint-Germain vous avez inventé une
cuisine de terroir avec des produits
frais de qualité accessible au plus
grand nombre vous qui avez pourtant été
élevé dans les cuisines du Ritz de la
Tour d'Argent et du crayon vous avez
suivi votre mentor Christian Constant
vous avez révolutionné le monde de la
restauration parisienne en vous
focalisant sur le produit le goût du
vrai de l'authentique vous étiez à
l'avant-garde du local devenu le maître
mot des consommateurs avertis le local
justement et bien on va le retrouver
dans le menu du jour j' oui avec un menu
qui sent le sud une brandade de Moru et
en dessert une crème caramel dans le
dessous des plats connaissez-vous la
bistronomie à l'atou d'un étoilé dans un
décor décontracté dégustation matré un
restaurant parisien du 18e
arrondissement dans les pieds dans le
plat comment se nourrissent les joueurs
de rugby de la collation d'avant match
au banquet final reportage à suivre
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et
confidence alors avec un convive comme
vous y chef et rudby man à la fois on ne
sait jamais à quoi s'attendre dans notre
assiette d'abord ça dépend de l'ORS du
match si on mange juste avant mauvaise
pioche ces pâtes pour les sucres LAN et
poulet pour les protéines pas très
glamour laissons ça au Malabar du 15 de
France en revanche si c'est après match
à en croire votre livre ovalx une
histoire gourmande du rugby que je
montre ici et bien la troisème mi-temps
c'est la régalade sans clin d'œil entre
banquet Brigitte et guuleton donc avec
Brigitte et bien on s'est mis à rêver
pourquoi pas ripailler ce soir avec un
FA de bohème sur crouade une truite
saumonnaée à la russe je n'invente rien
ce sont des plats tirés d'un menu de
1896 pour un match international de
l'Olympique et bien non on aura rien de
tout ça pour sortir de cette mêlée
gastronomique Yve vous avez pris tout le
monde à contrepied avec une brandade de
Moru qui je vous l'avoue me laisse panti
quel des aveux pour votre terroir de
peau et par ricochet pour votre club de
cœur la Section Paloise qui ne va pas
comprendre C Yade en direction du
hersénim ça mérite des éclaircissements
cette brandade mais parce que je pense
que c'est un plat de saison voilà c'est
un plat qui est en mi-chemin entre la
voilà la fin de l'été le le le début de
l'automne et puis c'est surtout un plat
qui a du caractère alors je suis du
Sud-Ouest mais j'aime la cuisine de
caractère peu importe d'où elle vient
l'important c'est pas laisser pas y
mettre de l'indifférence et la Branda
deoru c'est un très joli plat et un très
joli clin d'œil au terroir du Sud-Est
c'est c'est un plat que vous proposiez
vous dans vos restaurants oui oui j'en
avais systématiquement à la carte parce
que pour la petite histoire je l'ai pris
avaent papa parce que papa avait
travaillé dans les années 50 à Paris et
c'est à Paris qu'il avait appris à faire
la brand de morue alors c'est une brand
de morue particulière parce qu'elle est
un peu parmentière dire voilà qu'on on
est uncort voilà il y a plusieurs façons
de faire la brandade de morue mais j'ai
envie de de vous savez il y a la
tradition des des grandes classiques
français il y a autant de recettes que
nous avons de grand-mères chaque famille
a son secret chaque famille a sa façon
de faire et alors la brandade parmtia
c'est une Moru qui a était poché souvent
dans du lait parfumé avec de l'ail du
thin et du laurier qu'on égoûte qu'on
monte à l'huile d'olive avec un ail
haché écrasé et après on y rajoute voilà
une purée de pommes de terre pour y
amener un peu d'onctuosité alors là on
va appeler quand même Jean-Pierre à la
rescouse parce que est-ce qu'il y a de
pommes de terre dans la brandade
Jean-Pierre trois choses à savoir oui
alors trois choses à savoir mais je fait
preuve d'humidité devant un chef c'est
plutôt trois choses non mais c'est
plutôt trois choses à éclaircir vous
avez tout dit est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
des pommes de terre dans l'authentique
brandade oui ou non non il y en a pas la
vre auentique je l'ai d c'est brand
parmentière est-ce qu'il est préférable
de faire cuire l'AMU dans du lait et si
oui pourquoi là vous le faites cuire
dans du lait alors on le fait cuillère
d' du lait parce que déjà le le le lait
va dessaler plus plus plus pertinemment
que que l'eau et surtout le lait aussi
va blanchir un peu la morue qui peut
avoir étant donné qu'elle a été séchée
et salée et qui a des couleurs un peu
foncées ça permet d'avoir une brandade
avec une couleur un peu plus or et
est-ce que l'ail est indispensable pour
faire prendre la brandade parce que
brandade on va le dire ça vient de
brander ça veut dire un peu tourner hein
oui c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est écrasé
alors là il est indispensable je vais
vous dire euh pour mon épouse non elle
en veut pas mais moi j'en veux voilà
quand c'est une question de modération
c'est une question modération et c'est
une question de goût mais l'ail voilà
l'ail c'est pour moi indispensable parce
que là il est un exauceur de goût c'est
quelque chose qui va amener de la
profondeur et qui va permettre justement
de garder voilà un palais relativement
puissant mais tellement agréable on m'a
dit que ça favorisait l'émulsion aussi
avec l'huile et ça permet voilà ça
permet avec ça permet un liant à l'huile
d'olive voilà parce que quand on le fait
de façon classique on met pas de pomme
de terre c'est l'il qui va un ce côté
crémeux parce qu' on va mixer l'ail avec
l'huile on aura une forme de crème qui
va s'enrouler autour des de la morue
poché voilà je dit il y autant de
recettes que de grand-mère accep vous
aviez deux restaurants à la régalade le
comptoir du relais que vous n'avez plus
aujourd'hui alors un chef aujourd'hui
sans ses cuisines ça cuisine toujours à
la maison comment ça se passe
mais déjà quand j'avais encore m cuisin
je cuisinais quand même à la maison
cuisiner pour moi c'est c'est vital là
je suis incapable de passer une jour
vous derrière les fourneaux à la maison
voà bon même si mon épouse cuisine très
bien mais à 80 % c'est moi qui suis dans
les fourneaux parce que j'y prends un
réel plaisir et je suis dans mon élément
plus de plaisir peut-être parce que il y
a pas le client derrière parce que vous
êtes vous avez vot le temps pour le
faire c'est plus détenduors c'est
beaucoup plus détendu et je pense que je
détends inconsciemment et siamment je
détends beaucoup plus la mar la matière
première aussi parce que je lui amène
pas mon stress voilà qui qui est inérant
mon métier de de cuisine restaurateur là
je le fais vraiment dans une forme de
jovialité de décontraction et puis je
pense que je cuisine mieux à la maison
parce que j'ai moins de réflexion par
rapport au visuel voilà je vais qu'au
goût je vais prendre exemple de d'un
petit poid un petit po au restaurant
restera toujours vert fluo parce qu'il
aura été d'abord cuit dans de l'eau
salée glacé tandis qu'à la maison mais
je vais le cuire dans le jus du poulet
il va prendre cette couleur marbré qui n
visuellement pas très jolie mais
qu'est-ce que c'est meilleur parce que
le client c'est vous-même donc vous avez
moins d'exigence beaucoup moinsexigû moi
je trouve ça pas mauvais alors vous
allez nous dire ce que vous en pensez ça
ressemble à la brand c'est la recette de
chez Françoise le restaurant des
Invalides avec qui nous travaillons mais
j'ai l'impression que ça ressemble à la
parmentiè alors on est entre deux voilà
on est entre deux on est vraiment entre
entre les deux parce que là on ressent
quand même la puissance de la morue qui
est très présente et qui est très
agréable et la façon don j'ai appris
avec papa on est on est plus sur un
petit gratin de pomme de terre Moru où
il y a peut-être plus donctuosité mais
moins de puissance de Moru je pense que
l'amateur de Branda le puriste va adorer
va l'aimer comme ça va l'aimer comme ça
alors là il y a du poisson dans le
Sud-Ouest on est plutôt habitué à des
gésers à du canard et cetera vous vous
consommez comment aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui j'ai changé mon alimentation
maintenant il y a une bonne vingtaine
d'années parce qu'on a je pense que le
métier a pris conscience de
problématique qu'il y avait de la
surproduction de protéines animales donc
on on a énormément réduit notre
consommation de protéines animales je
dois consommer deux fois par semaine des
protéines animales et après le restant
c'est protéines végétales et énormément
de légumes et on peut dire merci à Alain
Passard qui a anobli voilà il y a bon
nombre d'anné maintenant mais qui a
anobli la façon de travailler le légume
on y met beaucoup d'intention maintenant
on y met beaucoup de précision sur la
cuisson des légumes et on arrive à faire
des plats qui sont succulents et des
plats qui gustativement apporte beaucoup
de plaisir et questions un Palois
toujours cette question épineuse elle
revient souvent sur cette table là
Brigit c'est le foie gras qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait on continue oui bien sûr
qu'on continue mais c'est comme tous ces
produits qui malheureusement ont été
pris par l'industrie agroalimentaire qui
a voulu les produire des quantités
énormes énormes et qui a complètement
déstabilisé le le produit par lui-même
voilà le foie gras qui est fait mais le
petit élveur il gave aussi son canard
oui mais il gave dans son canard mais il
faut savoir qu'un petit élveur qui gave
son canard il va le gaver à la main et
pour approcher un canard il faut que le
canard voilà il sentent de l'affection
et de l'amour c'est vraiment fait sans
mal maltraitance de l'animal donc oui
mais quand c'est des petites
exploitations c'est ce que vous dites
revenons à la petit mais le FO on peut
parler exactement du saumon le saumon
fumé c'est une catastrophe c'est une
catastrophe totale voilà les saumons
fumés fait l'élevage c'est une
catastrophe il faut revenir je pense à
des produits de façon artisanale en
petite quantité et respecter la saison
le foie gras on en mangé qu'à partir du
mois d'octobre novembre décembre janvier
et on a arrêté d'en manger local la
saisonnalité le bio aussi est-ce que
vous êtes un défenseur du bio oui le bio
c'est indispensable bio parce que tous
les entr chimiques on sait très bien que
l'entr chimique quel qu'il soit et est
dangereux pour la santé de de l'humain
donc il faut impérativement qu'on arrive
à consommer que des produits propres
mais ça marche pas le bio hein c'est
c'est une baisse record c'est très cher
les gens n'adhèrent pas forcément se per
dans tous les labels et finalement c'est
pas le bio qui privilégie parce que le
bio aussi est en train de grandir est en
train aussi de de se remettre en
question là il y a eu une une évol ution
assez incroyable du bio parce que tout
le monde s'en est emparé la son le bio à
la petite échelle c'est vrai que ça un
cout un peu plus élevé mais je pense je
crois que je préfère mettre 1 € de plus
dans une carotte et moins acheter de
médicaments c'est mon point de vue mais
est-ce qu'on peut nourrir toute la
population avec des petites
exploitations est-ce qu'il faut pas
aussi des plus grandes pour pouvoir
davantage on y arrivera sans doute pas
mais je pense que voilà les petites
exploitations doivent exister et on doit
respecter et la vraie question et la
vraie évolution passera par une
production conventionnelle par par par
l'agroalimentaire mais avec des règles
des règles sanitaires très strictes pour
qu'il puisse produire pour que tout le
monde puisse manger à sa fin mais de
façon propre alors un petit mot sur le
sur le vin parce que vous nous avez
demandé un vin nature alors un vin
nature c'est quoi bah c'est un vin qui
n'a pas de qui n'a pas de pesticides
dont les raisins sont bio aussi pas
d'herbicide pas d'engraé chimique aucun
in Tran effectivement vous l'avez dit
euh et puis surtout il y a pas de
sulfite ajouté donc c'est entièrement
naturel alors le risque c'est que ça
peut repartir un peu en fermentation
c'estàd qu'il peut être un peu Paris pas
non il y a pas de risque quand c'est
quand c'est bien fait il y a aucun
risque là faut que ce soit fait par des
par des vénirons et ça se fera pas du
jour au lendemain il faut déjà par
rapport au travail de la terre il faut
que la terre soit habitué à ce travail
voilà et que le raisin aussi soit
habitué à vivre sans entrant chimique
par rapport au CP de vigne et quand
c'est fait dans les règles de l'art de
façon classique et traditionnelle il y a
aucun risque parce que le problème du
vin nature aujourd'hui c'est qu'on parle
de nature et quand il y a des déviants
dans le vin on dit c'est normal que
c'est nature non c'est pas bon comme
dans le conventionnel quand c'est pas
bon c'est pas bon c'est qu'il est mal
fait donc là parce que le souffre permet
justement d'éviter cette altération
voilà après c'est il y a aussi le des
vin nature où il y a un minimum de
souffle qui a été mise justement parce
que pour stabiliser le vin faut pas être
contre ça non plus je pense qu'il faut
pas être totalement braquer par rapport
au aux aux entrans mais dans
l'absolution on peut le faire sans
entrant chimique c'est mieux pour la
santé c'est mieux pour voilà c'est mieux
pour la santé c'est mieux pour le
n'oublion pas c'est mieux pour nous donc
c'est allons vers çaite je j'ai une
question à vous poser un vin bio c'est
plus radical que non un vin nature c'est
plus radical qu'un vin bio c'est pas la
même chose c'est un peu plus radical
parce que oui parce qu'il y a aucun
parce qu' y a pas de souffre en fait
parce qu'il y a pas de
soufreans sulfit ajusté pour pour V
nature ça va un peu plus loin mais
n'oublion pas que ça doit être bon si
c'est pas bon peu importe si c'est bio
nature ou conventionnel quand c'est pas
bon c'est pas bon faut
l'assumer alors là on est sur un vin de
de Loire c'est un c'est un chinon
j'espère que ça se marie bien avec la
brandade de Moru justement c'est vrai
que quand on parle de brandade de Moru
on pourrait penser de suite Moru vin
blanc tandis que là c'est un gabernet
c'est gabernet franc je pense gabernet
Fran effectivement qui se qui se
qui qui tient bien bien justement par
rapport à Laamu qui un produit qui a du
caractère qui un produit qui est salé et
avec même le côté un peu aillé il est
vraiment en place et c'est un joli
mariage tout en fraîcheur voilà on est
plus sur le le fruit des fruits rougesou
complètement on est sur gros des fruits
rouges on croque on croque vraiment
dansà dans dans le côté très fruité de
la cerise de la framboise de la fraise
c'est très agréable alors vous êtes très
très fort évidemment parce que vous êtes
chez cuisiner mais on va voir si vous
êtes vraiment incollable c'est le
quiz
Brigitte l'a rappelé dans sa
présentation vous avez fait vos classes
à la Tour d'Argent qui vient justement
de rouvrir après des mois de travaux
titanesques c'était incroyable alors
sauriez-vous me dire à propos de cette
fameuse Tour d'Argent une institution de
la gastronomie française si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses
fondé en
1810 c'est le plus vieux restaurant de
France euh c'est faux bravo pourquoi
bravo parce que je crois que le plus
vieux restaurant de France c'est le
peut-être le Procope ou alors sur les
Saint-Louis un petit établissement dont
le nom m'échappe alors vous avez raison
mais vous avez pas la bonne explication
moi j'ai lu que c'était le plus vieux
restaurant de France mais où j'avais
fait un piège c'est que c'est pas en
1810 c'est en 1852 mais j'ai lu que
c'était plus vieux que le Procope ah je
doute parce que je pense qu'il y a un
établissement dans l'île SaintLouis et
je crois en tout les cas s présenté
comme le plus vieux restaurant on va fa
un on va fairecking je vous fa check j'
un fac quiz quiz alors le roi Henri
il dégustait à cette table du Héron
Farcy
euh oh il en était bien capable il en
était bien capable c'est un vrai
gastronome Henri c'est mon c'est mon roi
quand même il est né à poau au château
de poau je pense que oui j'en étais bien
capable alors je ne sais pas mais en
tous les cas ce que j'ai trouvé dans les
menus de l'époque c'était plutôt du
signe roti mais le héron je suis pas sûr
qu'on le on l'ouvrein et qu'on le
farcissait mais
peut-être c'est ici qui a été inauguré
pour la première fois l'usage dans cette
table de la fourchette oh non parce que
la fourchette c'est Caine de mesis en
France mais celle qui l'a amené à la
Renaissance
donc on va dire je sais pas je fais mon
joker alors j vous avez raison vous avez
bien commencé caerine dominiis la
Toscane la fourchette vient d'Italie et
c'est effectivement à la Tour d'Argent
que la première fois et bien les clients
ont mangé avec cet ustensile ass
pratique finalement on gardé après avec
les doigts hein je sais pas non comm non
pas les doigts peut-être aussi avec des
des couverts en desql ou des bois le
bois le bois vaêtre beaucoup utilisé sa
question pour aussi Brigitte les caves
du restaurant oui abritent 80000
bouteilles euh
oui là je dis oui parce que je les ai
visité et c'est un labyrinthe et
d'ailleurs je crois que il y a 4 C
sous-sols en dessous de la scène et
raconté par Monsieur Terrail pendant la
guerre la deème guerre mondiale ils
avaient même pour pas que les Allemands
viennent voler les bouteilles ils
avaient carrément muré des des couloirs
ils sont pas sûrs de les avoir tous
démurés ah il y en a peut-être plus
qu'on croit ouais je pense que les 80000
bouteilles il sont ouais mais alors vous
aviez dû boire un verre quand vous avez
fait ce tour parce qu'il y en avait
350000 et vous les avez pas compté ah
ouais 350000 bouteilles à mon avis quand
on voit 80000 on sait pas s'il y en a
bouteillesent vraiment si vous avez
l'occasion deeriter c'est incroyable à
voir c'est un labyrinthe et si vous ça
descend je CIS 4 c enous de la SC ah
ouais et quand il y a des inondations
des crues alors ils ont tout un système
de de pompe justement pour éviter les
inondation ser une catastrhe c'est
fabuleux à visiter ah oui j'imagine
alors vous allez pouvoir vous rattraper
avec un deuxième quiz de quel pays parmi
les 20 engagés dans cette Coupe du monde
de rugby le cocoda plat de poisson cru
au lait de coco est-il originaire le
cocoda alors à la Nouvelle-Zélande B les
FIDGI C l'Uruguay et d les îles
Tonga alors bon l'Uruguay je dis non la
Nouvelle-Zélande je dis non c'est soit
les Tongas soit les FIDI et dans mon
imaginaire je suis jamais allé sur les
île FIDI mais on voit souvent des
reportages sur les plages les joueurs
fidgiens jouant sous les cocotiers donc
je vaux dire les fidgis bravo
félicitations c'est exactement ça ou
alors pour l'anecdote le Tonga ils ont
un peu la même recette mais elle
s'appelle pas cocoda donc le cocoda
c'est bien
bravo alors c'est souvent autour de de
la table et à l'occasion d'un d'un
déjeuner vous le savez mieux que moi que
les langues se délient qu' y a
finalement les meilleures histoires qui
sont racontées et bien c'est ce qu'on a
appelé la brève de
comptoir alors IFC Deborne on vous a
demandé de de réfléchir du coup à une
anecdote autour d'un d'un repas et si
possible en politique est-ce qu'il y en
a une qui vous est revenue à l'esprit
ouii il y en a une qui elle m'est pas
revenue parce qu'elle elle est ancrée
elle est ancrée en moi c'est je crois en
1998 quand il y avait eu la grève des
pilotes d'Air France voilà c'était
vraiment une grève qui avait duré et qui
avait été très très engagé et j'avais
Christian Paris qui était un ami et qui
était le syndicaliste qui menait cette
grève voilà qui était pilote à Air
France qui était très engagé contre le
contre le ministre de l'époque é un
ministre qui était de Bézier s'appelait
pardon qui s'appelait monsieur
guesso et c'est Michel palmier Michel
palmier ce qu'on appelait la la momie
qui était l'emblématique seconde ligne
de l'équipe de France de rugby de la
grande époque de l'équipe de Bézier qui
avait 10 titres de champion de France
voilà qui connaissait les deux et qui à
un moment donné m'a me dit parce que il
savait qu'il vouait tous tout le monde
venait manger à la maison mais de façon
de façon individuelle à la régalade à la
régalade et qui me dit Yve faut qu'on
dénoue ça prépare-moi une table je vais
les amener je vais les asseoir face à
face à table voilà il me dit tu veas
voir la table ça ça calme tout le monde
ça met tout le monde au même niveau tu
vas faire un repas gargantuesque et on
va discuter et donc Michel Pamier a
réussi à faire venir monsieur le
ministre et et Christian Paris ils se
sont assis tous les trois ils étaient
tous les trois tous les troispp la table
la table neu c une table qui était à
part ils se sont mis à table à midi ils
en sont sortis à quelle heure il était
pratiquement 20h le soir ah B ils sont
rentrés en discussion avec un accord
alors avec oui avec un accord ils sont
sortis avec un accord mais surtout
durant le repas une fois de plus le fait
de manger le fait de partager permet je
trouve permet aux gens de
s'écouter qu'est-ce que vous leur avez
préparé parce que forcément il devit y
avoir quelque chose de bon dans
l'assiette je leur avais préparé à
l'époque j'avais fait une tarte de
Saint-Jacques on faisit une tarte de
Saint-Jacques feuilletée avec du lar et
des oignons on avait fait un bœuf
Bourguignon voilà un beau fromage de
brebill des Pyréné et le fameux gâteau
russe c'est le gâteau rus c'est un
gâteau une spécialité de laoron
Sainte-Marie que je recevais de mon ami
Michel artigared donc j'avais fait ce
repas et ça avait apaiser tout le monde
et à la fin de la journée et ben il
s'étaient salué ils s'étaient embrassé
et ils avaient dit c'est fini j'étais
très fier d'avoir vécu ce moment-là
parce que pour moi la table a toujours
été un moyen de discuter un moyen de
partager un moyen voilà de m'engager je
me suis mais on peut se disputer aussi à
table ça peut il pas de famille c'est
parfois un peu on est on est on est à
égalité moi je j'auris jamais pu me
disputer voilà j'aurais jamais pu me
disputer avec une personnalité dans la
rue en en le rencontrant mais une fois
que j'étais assis à table voilà je
n'avais plus aucun complexe je libérais
ma parole j'avais une franchise
naturelle et je crois que ce jourl voilà
la table a amené la franchise et amené
aussi voilà le bon sens le bon sens de
bien manger et le bon sens de bien
comprendre est-ce que vous avez la
modeste prétention de penser que ce que
vous avez fourni à ces convives les
plats ont permis diplomatiquement de
nouer ce cet accord si vous aviez servi
quelque chose d'urticquant de de clivant
ça aurait pas joué le même rôle mais
sans doute mais c'est surtout un état
d'esprit mais ça avait été fait avant
moi Bria savarin le grand Bria savarin
c'était taillerant le ministre qu'
l'avait engagé à son service quand il y
avait des grandes des grandes réunions
politiques en France justement pour
adoucir voilà tous les tous les autres
présidents des autres pays qui veut
rencontrer parce qu'ils savaient
pertinemment que la gastronomie
française estun gastronomie qui est
respectée et quand on mange de la
gastronomie française on respecte le
moment alors grâce à vous on va on va
continuer à mettre en lumière cette
belle cuisine française
grce et je rends hommage à Michel
palmier et à Christian et à Monsieur
guesso parce que voilà je pense qu' à
tous les Quates chacun avec notre notre
savoir on on était arrivé à dénouer une
situation qui paraissait indénouable
inextricable bravoépoque c'était déjà
savoir-fire bien français la bistronomie
vous en êtes l'inventeur de cette
cuisine mibistro migastro c'est le
dessous des
plats une une cuisine raffinée et
inventive mais dans un cadre simple
voilà la définition de la bistronomie
née dans les années 90 elle a fait
florese dans la restauration avec des
produits de qualité à des prix
exceptionnels et les clients ne s'y
trompent pas ils sont au rendez-vous
comme ici au matré où mait Frémont et
Raphaël inzamba sont allés à la
rencontre d'un chef que vous connaissez
bien dans ce restaurant les tables sont
simples le style celui d'un bist trop
typique mais ici le client est bien loin
d'une nourriture parfois
ordinaire le produit est hyper important
c'est que donner autant d'attention un
filet de macro qui un filet de barre et
cetera ou qu'un Homar et cetera pour moi
c'est ça vraiment l'idée de la
bistronomie du très bon à un prix
raisonnable c'est le défi que se sont
lancé Lucas en cuisine et Chloé en salle
les ingrédients sont ultra frais comme
ce ton de 5 kg que le chef cuisine ce
matin ça c'est un ton qui a été pêché
dans l'Atlantique par ce qu'on appelle
des petits bateaux donc qui a été pêché
à la ligne pas par des gros chalu qui
détruisent tout machin truc tu vois tu
me demandais ce que c'est la bistronomie
c'est aussi savoir utiliser les
choses et pas forcément jeter cette
partie là elle va être super pour faire
du cru du Tartare des machins comme ça
et ça il y a un chou à plus de Neer on
va le cuire au menu ton snacké à la
sauce tomate piment fumé avec des figues
des capres et de la Roquette une
assiette de bistro travaillée comme dans
un restaurant gastronomique 28 € le menu
quatre fois moins qu'une table étoilée
moins sélecte et plus conviviale une
précision décontractée découverte chez
vous ifcand Debord Lucas a fait ses
classes dans vos cuisines et voilà ce
qu'il en retient m' pris les pommes de
fil de son grandpère je sais pas
forcément techniquement ce qui m'a
appris je pense que c'est vraiment une
de philosophie quoi cette cuisine de
haute volée plus abordable vous en êtes
le pilier retour dans les années 90 la
régalade votre restaurant va révéler un
nouveau courant la bistronomie on peut
très bien exister se faire plaisir
professionnellement donner du plaisir à
ses clients sans être obligé de
s'identifier à une institution privée
qui nous casse les pieds le concept un
succès fou le terme bistronomie entre
même dans le Larousse définition cuisine
raffinée et inventive de type
gastronomique mais servie dans un
restaurant simple non nettoilé ben il
est vrai qu'après tout le monde a
cherché à s'approprier cette bistronomie
qui était une espèce de martingale de
recette à succès et c'est comme ça
qu'aujourd'hui bah la bistronomie
qualifie une réalité extrêmement diverse
et après vous mettez désormais sous le
terme de listronomie un peu tout et
n'importe quoi elle est quand même là la
réité alors RC de bord dans cette
bistronomie de 2023 y a-t-il vraiment à
boire et à
manger réponse y a-t-il vraiment à boire
et à manger oui bien sûr qu' y a pe qui
a à boire et à manger parce que voilà
ils ont tout le monde veut s'approprier
ce ce terme qui a été inventé qui a été
dit la première fois par Sébastien
Demorand voilà moi j'avais jamais parlé
voulu faire ce voulu faire ce que j'ai
ce qu'on m'a dit c'estd que Sébastien de
il vous gne ce il im'agè à une époque
oui im'agè à une époque parce que quand
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
Sébastien demoran critique gastronomique
qui a disparu mais grand bonhomme qui
était un de vos un des journalistes
gastronomiqu qui m'a le plus apporté
intellectuellement de par ses jugements
et de par ses critiques et Sébastien m'a
dit un jour Yve tu fais de la
bistronomie voilà c'est parti c'est
parti comme ça donc c'est devenu un
terme maintenant très marketing très
médiatique qui des fois frise le
ridicule mais le contreexemple c'est le
matr voilà c'est vrai que le Matra Lucas
et Chloé se sont lancés sans argent
voilà c'est eux qui ont peint ils ont
pas appelé un architecte c'est eux qui
ont qui ont mis la lumière ils ont pas
pr appelé un designer ils sont
débrouillés avec leurs mains avec leur
cœur mais surtout ils ont pensé que
qu'une chose c'est donner de la
personnalité donner de l'amour et faire
une assiette d'exception et c'est ça la
bistrom mais qu'est-ce qui vous gêne
dans la bistronomie aujourd'hui quand on
dit qu'elleer décrier c'est parce qu'il
y a un très joli décor et que finalement
s retrouve pas dans l'assiette par si on
prend historiquement moi je sors du riz
du crayon des grandes maison je quitte
ça pour aller dans un endroit me dire
voilà je veux que le plus grand nombre
puisse bien manger dans un dans un dans
un esprit totalement décontracté donc
tout le décor h je l'enlève totalement
je pense qu' une chose c'est que
l'assiette aujourd'hui malheureusement
voilà on fait encore à nouveau une fois
de plus on remet des codes de partout on
remet du décorome avec VO je dis le
designer à la
mode vos copains rbyan vous c'est pas
mes copains rudbyan c'est pour faire
c'est pour nourrir les gens et dire qu'à
un moment donné que le restaurant on est
en train de faire des musées que pour
aller au restaurant si on n' pas les
codes si on a pas les bons comportements
on ne peut plus y aller un restaurant ça
doit rester un lieu de vie voilà quand
on rentre dans dans un restaurant on
doit pas se prendre la tête à être mal à
l'aise parce qu'on se dit ouis mais
l'ambiance ça joue beaucoup aujourd'hui
quand même euh pour se sentir bien dans
un lieu euh oui il faut aller au musée
il faut aller au musée il faut aller au
théâtre voilà leur restaurant avant de
tout c'est bien manger voilà moi j'ai
pas envie de payer trois fois plus cher
parce que on va m'expliquer que les les
rideaux c'est Stark ou c'est les rideaux
de pierrefais ça ne m'intéresse pas qu'
me disent que la volaille elle vient de
chez pler duup Plantier une volaille
d'exception qui est fait par un un
personnage extraordinaire qui respecte
ses animaux et qui tous les jours nous
amène voilà une matière première qui est
juste incroyable et comme la fasse
déguster moi ce que je veux c'est
l'émotion du palais l'émotion de voilà
de de toute ma sensibilité olfactive et
et gustative c'est tout ce qui nous
intéresse al pour vous les les codes de
la bistronomie c'est c'est quoi c'est du
100 % français dans
l'assiette loc c'est de la qualité
supérieure non c'est c'est c'est pas
tellement du 100 % français bien sûr si
on peut faire du français mais pourquoi
s' interdire de prendre un produit qui
vient de l'étranger qui est exceptionnel
et le locavor aussi bien sûr que si on
peut utiliser un maximum de produit
locavor mais moi qui suis béarné c'est
pas parce que je suis en béarne que j'ai
pas avoir le droit de faire des endives
j'aime les endives je vois pas pourquoi
je pourrais pas faire venir des endives
du Nord fait par un artisan c'est pour
ça que pour moi c'est la limite du
locavor mais après c'est vrai que si je
prends de l'agneau si je suis en béne il
faut que je prenne l'agneau des Pyrénées
que je ne fasse pas venir l'agneau du
montsmichel mais et après laabistronomie
après la définition pour moi c'est une
assiette d'exception à un prix
accessible dans une très bonne ambiance
c'était la contraction de bistro et de
gastronomie d'ailleurs mais alors quels
sont les plats qui incarnent parce
qu'effectivement il l'a dit François ris
gr c'est un peu à boire et à manger tout
et n'importe quoi quels sont pour vous
si tant que ça existe les plats qui
incarnent cette bistronomie il y a pas
de plat qui incarne la bistronomie parce
queon peut très bien faire un turbo au
caviar dans la bistronomie mais au lieu
de le vendre 250 € on va le vendre que
50 € vendez à
per pas Perre on le caviard c'est un
prix je je prends peut-être un plat
exagéré mais mais c'est exactement mais
philosophiquement c'est ça c'estàd qu'on
va pas le vendre à Pertre on n'est pas
obligé de faire un coefficient de 10
donc c'est pas forcément un petit lé
c'est quand même une critique c'est
quand même une une critique très forte
contre les étoiletes ce que vous nous
dites là c'est qu'en fait ils font des
marges éénor et que non mais non mais
ils font des marges énormes ils font des
marges énormes parce qu'ils sont obligés
de les faire parce que le verre que moi
je vais prendre le verre que j'achète en
mistronomie qui coûte 2 50 eux ils vont
prendre un ZTO qui coûte 80 € d'accord
voilà il y a une logique mais attention
attention je reviens dessus je ne dis
pas voilà je ne dis pas que la haute
gastronomie euh vole le client ah non
c'est ce n'est pas vrai
il gag ils gagn peut-être moins d'argent
que dans la bistronomie en finalité mais
ils sont dans l'excellence de tout donc
obligatoirement le prix est dans
l'excellence il y a une une logique à
tout le même vin qu'on va acheter en
bistronomie on va faire un coefficient
de TR eux vont faire un coefficient de 4
ou 5 ou 6 est-ce qu'il y a exigence en
cuisine que dans un restaurant
gastronomique c'est la même exigence
c'est exactement la même justement c'est
toute la différence elle est là si la
bistronomie on a Luc le dit bien on a la
même exigence c'est une obligation mais
attention on a sous l'intelligence voilà
de de savoir qu'on est pas 15 en cuisine
qu'on est que deux en cuisine donc on va
aller des fois un peu plus de simplicité
technique que quand on va prendre un
maqueron on va prendre le même macro
qu'on pourrait acheter que Eric Fréchon
achète au au Bristol le même la même
qualité au même prix mais nous on va
simplement le lever on va le poiler on
va l'agrémenter une petite garniture ERC
va faire un travail totalement différent
avec beaucoup plus d'intervention de la
main et beaucoup plus de technique donc
obligatoirement ça coûtera plus cher
mais gustativement après voilà le le les
goûts ce sont deux goûts d'exception
c'est pas moins ambitieux de vouloir
faire de la bistronomie quand on a été
au rit dans des très grandes maisons
comme vous non je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus humain voilà parce que
c'est beaucoup plus humain parce que on
est proche de nos clients on on aime nos
clients on le voit avec Lucas il a la
cuisine ouverte il a envie d'embrasser
tout le monde tout le monde va lui dire
bonjour Voilà c'est qu'on a besoin
humainement de de de vivre le moment
avec intensité Sant la haute gastronomie
voilà c'est le côté parfait très très
rigide très très organisé très structuré
où il y a pas il y a pas le droit de
voilà de transpirer il y a pas le droit
de d'exister hors hors de l'assiette
tandis que le bistronome a envie
d'exister hors de l'assiette c'est pas
aussi une façon de renoncer au à
l'étoilet à cette charge mentale de se
dire bah je fais bien mon métier
parfaitement je m'encouvre pas de cette
charge de l'éto c'est là quiil sont idot
voilà c'est là qu'il se sont trompés je
pense c'est là qu'ils ont loupé un coche
voilà parce que quoi qu'ils disent dans
tout leur discours qu'on a entendu
depuis des années des années quand ils
disent c'est que l'assiette que
l'assiette l'assiette on sait très bien
que c'est pas vrai et je crois que
là-dessus Michelin fait une énorme
erreur voilà d'avoir d'avoir totalement
délaissé la C bistronoui pendant des
années et des années parce que je je
j'ai le défi de prendre une assiette
finie d'un bistr qui est bien faite la
déplacer la mettre dans une grande
maison avec le décorome et là il aura
son étoile voilà donc toute toute la
problématique Eric Fréchon Eric Fréchon
à La Verrière 0 étoil il passe au
Bristol l'année après de étoiles et Eric
c'est un ami il a pas changé sa cuisine
hein voilà il a la même philosophie il
avait la même précision dans dans dans
dans la verrière à l'époque qu'il a
aujourd'hui au Bristol il y a une
dictature des étoiles aujourd'hui dans
la gastronomie dans il a une dictature
c'est faut pas oublier que c'est quand
même un organisme privé euh donc si on a
envie de leur dire un gros mot on peut
leur dire hein voilà c'est un peu ce que
vous avez fait finalement oui poliment
poliment poliment poliment non mais
parce que j'aiété déçu de de leur part
parce que voilà j'aiétéis déçu parce que
j'ai travaillé dans un TR étoil Michelin
où c'était une catastrophe et çaait tr
étoiles Michelin voilà un restaurant
qu'on a cité tout à l'heure tu vois ceux
qui ceux qui acultent les tendances de
la cuisine française aujourd'hui disent
c'est le retour de la cuisine bourgeoise
alors quelle est la différence entre la
cuisine bourgeoise et cette bistronomie
parce que la cuisine bourgeoise c'est
aussi une cuisine avec des bons produits
hein des faisant alors c'est une cuisine
un peu au coin du feu c'est ça la
différence il y a moins d'innovation
moins de création on ressort des vieux
des vieilles traditions la cuisine
bourgeoise c'est la cuisine qui
réapparaît c'est la cuisine familiale
quoi la cuisine familiale qui était
faite de de de plats très chaleureux ça
une cuisine de bistronomie la cuisine
familiale oui mais mais ça peut être
aussi oui mais ça peut être aussi une
cuisine de gastronomie voilà si un bœuf
Bourguignon fait fait par par jean-f fr
jean-fançois piège dans son deux étoil
Michelin ça sera merveilleux c'est sûr
et certain mais alors comment vouz les
usagers les clients s
retrouvent gastomie laine
bouroise il commence à y avoir trop
d'appellations c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on a un retour voilà on a une période
très espagnole avec la la tendance
espagnole de FERR Adrien on a eu une
tendance très asiatique qui dure encore
un petit peu on a une tendance très
scandinave avec tout ce qui s'est passa
en Scandinavie dans la haute gastronomie
et aujourd'hui voilà une fois qu'on a
fait un le tour on est en train de se
voilà de de se dire en fin de compte le
plus beau des voyages vous savez ce que
c'est le plus beau des voyages c'est
faire le tour de soi-même et quand on a
fait le tour de soi-même on se dit mais
en fin de compte c'est pas si mal que ça
et on se dit pourquoi on ferait pas un
saucisse purée fait à la perfection avec
des très bons produits avec des très
bons produits et pourquoi en finalité
l'émotion du goût l'émotion que que le
palais pourrait nous en dégager est pas
aussi beau a aussi jouissif qu'un
cavière d'exception alors la cuisine
française a été beaucoup copiée est-ce
que la bistronomie elle est copiée
est-ce qu'on la retrouve à l'étranger
est-ce qu'il nous envie c ces petits
bistr avec une cuisine excellente moi je
ça moi je toujours beaucoup pas pas
d'émotion du tout en plus mais beaucoup
de toujours très surpris de me balader
dans le monde entier et de voir l'
mobistronomie apparaître partout quoi
parce que dans n'importe quel pays le M
bistronomie même au Japon ils le mettent
pas en japonais c'est marqué en
bistronomie au départ c'est un phénomène
parisien c'est un phénomène du 14e
arrondissement qui a gagné Paris qui a
gagné la province et qui a gagné le
monde exporté dans le monde entier des
fois personne sait qui je suis quand je
passe de de tendance non vous rendrez
compte que ça a été fait 49 avenu Jean
Moulin un restaurant qui a été peint par
mes copains de rugby les tables on les a
acheté au Rabé au puces et aujourd'hui
vous faites de la résistance il peuent
pas non mais ils peuvent pas s'imaginer
ça parce qu'on l'a fait avec nos valeurs
on l'a faitre cur et surtout on l'a fait
sans savoir ce qu'on faisait la seule
chose que j'avais envie c'est respecter
mon métier respecter tous les maîtres
qui m'ont appris à travailler de faire
une accè d'exception mais le faire dans
la jouissance et donner du bonheur à
tout le monde que le plaisir de bien
manger c'est pas réservé qu'on doit en
France le malheur le malheur aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a encore des gens qui
malheureusement mangent mal et ont pas
de plaisir à manger c'est ça le le vrai
drame et c'était mon ambition de de me
dire je vais essayer de faire plaisir au
plus grand nombre alors il y en a
d'autres qui sont en train de nous faire
plaisir c'est les joueurs de l'équipe du
monde de de rugby parce qu'il y a la
Coupe du monde alors on verra siil a l'
équipe du monde on sait pas encore mais
en tout pour l'instant c'est déjà bien
parti parce que vous vous êtes un
amateur du ballon oval vous avez été un
grand joueur aussi et vous êtes
capitaine du 15 de la gastronomie et
vous êtes auteur de ce livre co-auteur
ovalix on l'a dit qui mêle donc les
recettes et puis aussi un peu la 3è
mi-temps mais pour assurer sur le
terrain ben il faut quand même manger
équilibré alors on en parle et on met
les pieds dans le
plat alors if c'est sans doute lié à
leur Garbe le gabarit hornme les
rudbyman aiment plutôt bien manger on
connaît leur passion pour les troè
mi-temps pasagéique mais attention avant
les matchs la diététique reprend ses
droits mieux manger pour être performant
pierre Michael Carniel et Vincent
Ferrera se sont rendus à porort Debou à
l'occasion du Mondial amateur de rugby
reportage aujourd'hui on fait tomber de
suite les règles français c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faut les jouer contre
des gros on les prend on les fait tomber
aux jambes il faut pas qu'il fasse 1 m
aux jambes aux jambes aux jambes aux
jambes toute la partie il faut de
dévorer ses adversaires le match se
déroule déjà dans les assiettes les
joueurs du Rugby Club de digneolbain
représentent la France ils mangent 3h
avant le premier match un repas sur
mesure ces colosses ont besoin d'un
import calorique de 4000 kcalories par
jour contre 2500 en moyenne pour un
homme adulte bon c'est un repas sportif
hein qui est composé de poulet de pâte
de lentilles une
madeleine un yaourt et les couverts
évidemment de l'eau la bière à
[Rires]
serpré des glucides des lipides mais
aussi beaucoup de protéines le rugby
amateur s'inspire des codes
nutritionnels des sportifs de haut
niveau s faire de pub c'est sûr que si
vous mangez un fast food avant le match
ça va pas être la même chose que si vous
mangez des des féculant le midi c'est
clair après c'est sûr que les
professionnels ils ont des
diététiciennes des des personnes qui qui
gèent leur alimentation après nous on
essaie de faire attention quand même
mais après voilà ça reste quand même
amateur donc on peut pas contraindre les
les garçons à manger équilibré tous les
jours avec des menus
adapté ce jour-là les Français
affrontent une équipe néozélandaise elle
aussi semble avoir
faim et quand les rencontres
s'enchaînent les joueurs peuvent perdre
jusqu'à 2 l d'eau par heure alors même
la composition de l'eau n'est pas
laissée au hasard la récupère les gars
allez en fait pour pour pour la mi-temps
essentiellement on rajoute un petit peu
de compléments pour la récupération donc
dedans il y a du sucre des Seles
minéraux ENF plusieurs petites choses
très très important et surtout pour la
suite parce qu'on a une accumulation de
match on a une deuxème deuxè match
derrière donc il faut que tous les
organismes soient toujours prêts les All
Blacks amateurs l'emportent contre
l'équipe des Bleus mais peu importe le
score place à la célèbre 3è mi-temps
toutes les équipes partagent ce qu'elles
appellent un guuleton un repas copieux
et festif et du coup on mange tous
ensemble religieusement une soupe de
poisson euh bien marseillaise ça tranche
un peu avec le repas de ce midi du coup
ce midi c'était très hasxé protéin
sucrelant ce soir c'est plus l'ambiance
à la bonne humeur on a passé une bonne
journée ça pti quo voilà ça P
TI et là surtout c'est un moment de
convivialité de partage Parce que le
rugby amateur c'est surtout ça c'est le
rugby c'est l'ovaler c'est les copains
et on est tous ensemble
on partage un beau moment de
convivialité et on se permet même
quelques excès et moi je préfère le
rouge dans un
verreel il au moins
de alors j'ai lu ça et vous avez dû
connaître cette époque dans les années
80 on disait que l'équipe de France
avant un match dévorait un pentagruali
cassoulet ça c'est plus possible
aujourd'hui avant un match oui c'est
plus possible faut pas oublier que dans
les années 80 le Rud était encore sport
totalement amateur ça a simplement
changé en c'était l'équipe de France
quand même he oui mais l'équipe de
France c'était aussi des amateurs quand
même donc ils avaient le comportement de
d'un jeu amateur aujourd'hui il faut
manger vraiment équilibré pour être un
grand sportif
enfinou pé de toute façon on voit déjà
par par rapport au corps des joueurs de
rugby qui sont V des athlètes c'est
c'est pratiquement moi je dis toujours
ils ressemblent tous à des des catoniens
ils sont ils sont ils sont magnifiques
donc l'alimentation est très importante
l'alimentation est primordiale et ils
font très attention mais ce qui empêche
pas par exemple après la Coupe du Monde
il y aura un joli banquet voilà un joli
banquet il y a toujours des troisè
mi-temps alors oui parce que c'est les 3
temps elles font partie de la culture de
rugby parce que c'est un moment de
fraternité VO c'est un peu ce que j'ai
vécu moi avec avec avec Monsieur
monsieur guesso monsieur palmier et
Monsieur Paris c'est que la table fait
qui a un partage qui a de l'amour qui
qui s'instaure et qui amène beaucoup de
de de lien et cette fameuse fraternité
qui fait partie vraiment de l'ADN du
rugby vous vous faisiez justement vivre
cette table avec vos copains du rugby
quand vous étiez joueurs oui oui on on
perpétuait ces traditions et c'était
très moi qui cuisin oui parce un petit
club nous c'est un petit club vraiment
très amateur de 3e division il y avait
toujours un barbecue il y avait toujours
quelqu'un au grillade et souvent moi en
tant que cuisinier je me retrouva au
grillad vous connaissez F Tiolier c'est
la nutritionniste du 15 de France vous
avez des contacts avec elle vous l'aidez
à discuter parce que vous aimez bien la
bouffe plaisir pour rid bean parce que
qu'est-ce qui mange le 15 de France
avant qu'est-ce qu'ils vont manger par
exemple avant le match contre l'Italie
qui se profile al je pense non non je je
l'aide pas du tout parce que c'est une
professionnelle et je pense que moi j'ai
pas les compétences pour de diététicien
pour accompagner de caiss de France je
suis plus intervenant sur
le l'prémch non mais ils vont ils vont
manger équilibré ça fait de est-ce que
tout est pesé le moindre gram de protéin
pesé peut-être pas quand même mais
l'équilibre nutritionnel c'est sûr qu'
qu'il est là et surtout il y a un
équilibre nutritionnel qui est fait en
fonction de chaque individu par
voilà quand on nourrit un joueur
commeonio qui fait 150 kg et qu' on
nourrit à côté de ça un un Tom à Ramos
voilà c'est pas c'est pas du tout la
même la même il y a pas besoin de la
même quantité ni la même sans doute du
du même équilibre nutritionnel donc
chacun a vraiment un équilibre
nutritionnel alors il y a ce livre là
ovalix que vous avez coécrit il y a
beaucoup de recettes à l'intérieur c'est
quoi l'histoire de ces recettes avec
avec finalement le le 15 alors ovalix on
l'a écrit je l'ai coécrit avec Olivier
margaot Olivier margaot qui est un
l'ancien rédacteur en chef pendant 25
ans de du journal L'Équipe et amoureux
de rugby ancien joueur de rugby donc
l'idée part de se dire le banquet est
quelque chose de très important et il
faut qu'on le mette en valeur voilà
alors qu'on est allé rechercher des
vieux banquet voà des vieux menus de
banquet souvent c'est pour des matchs
assez historiques dans l'histoire de de
la gastro de la de la rugby français
donc il y a les menus il a les men voilà
et dans chaque donc Olivier raconte le
dernier même he sais que dernière
Olivier raconte un peu l'histoire du
match voilà moi j'en raconte aussi
certaines que que j'ai que j'ai vécu il
raconte l'histoire du banquet et
systématiquement par rapport à chaque
menu je retire une matière première du
menu et je m'amuse à faire une recette
alors une recette qui est facile à faire
en me disant si j'ai des copains qui
vont venir voir le match de rugby cet
après-midi qu'est-ce que je peux leur
faire assez assez facilement donc il a
c'est plutôt à picorer ou c'est c'est
plus à picorer sur té VO picorer devant
la devant la télé met des recettes
engagées comme au rugby des recettes qui
ont voilà qui ont qui ont du caractère
qui où il y a pas d'indifférence qui
vont être surprenantes mais des recettes
plaisir et surtout des recettes
accessibles à tout le monde alors pas
qu'à picoré Brigit parce que le magret
canard en carpachoouis mais ça c'est à
picoré totalement on pe picor oui mais
il faut des petites fourchettes d'accord
oui picoré attention je dis avec une pe
fourchette ou a BRI peut penser
peut-être au
snacking la tarte saint là
qui ça ça se partage voilà non non mais
tout des idées aussi he peut-être
personnes qui n regardidige COFI et
cette huile salée ça se partage moins ou
alors il faut boire dans la même oui il
peut avoir trois pailles TR paill après
chaque en plus chaque plat a a aussi une
petite histoire par rapport au match
voilà par exemple vous parlez de la
tarte au chocolat tarte au chocolat a
été créée par Cristian constant quand on
était à l'hôtel crayon pour les joueurs
de l'équipe de France des fin des années
80 dont Pascal hdars qui réire la scubé
parce qu'ils étaient gourmands ils
étaient fanatiques du chocolat et
capitale du chocolat en France c'est
Bayon donc on a voulu rendre hommage un
peu à T tous ces joueurs qui arrivés du
Pays-Basque en leur créant cette tarte
au chocolat h je l'ai vu la tarte au
chocolat alors vous êtes aussi capitaine
du 15 de la gastronomie euh
racontez-nous cette histoire parce que
vous intervenez aussi sur cette coupe du
monde de rugby oui j'interviens sur la
Coupe du monde du rugby c'est une idée
au départ de de Claude Hatcher qui nous
a qui m'a contacté pour me dire ce
serait bien voilà que pour une fois une
coupe du monde voilà de de rugby surtout
en France on on met en valeur la haute
gastronomie parce qu'il y a le rugby
reconnu mais la gastronomie et c'est la
plus belle gastronomie au monde c'est la
gastronomie française et cl m'a demandé
d'accompagner donc tous les Traiteurs de
France voilà qui ont qui interviennent
dans les stades dans les neu stades et
on est 23 cuisiniers voilà on comm une
équipe un 15 à 23 bon il aement on est
15 on on est en r on est 23 on est 15
qui jouent et avec les h remplaçants
donc on a accompagné les traiteurs on a
choisi avec les menus on a imposé un
cahier des charges qui est un cahier des
charges recette régionale recette de
saison et un maximum de produits locavor
là ça a été fait en amont depuis 2 ans
on a énormément travaillé à main dans la
main avec tous les traiteurs et
aujourd'hui on est trois par stade par
match il y a systématiquement trois
membres du 15 laastronomief par donc pas
la même chose à Marseille qu'à Lille non
just voilà c'est exactement ce qu' on
voulait on voulait pas voilà uneformité
globale de l'ensemble du territoire on
voulait que chaque région chaque stade
transpire et sent la gastronomie sont
des traiteurs locaux hein ce sont pas
les grands chefs qui
c'est que des traiteurs locaux qu'on
accompagne dans les grands chefs il y a
Alain Ducas Jean-François Piège
Alexandre Gautier Christian Cheb
Stéphanie le kelc Amandine cheno Christ
TR Brua c'est que des amoureux de ce
sport et des amoureux de de la
gastronomie et on s'est mis au service
totalement bénévolement de ce magnifique
événement qui est en train de se passer
en France et d'ailleurs on est très fier
parce que quand on rentre dans les
stades on voit cette bouille réjouie de
l'ensemble des des spectateurs en train
de consommer ça peut être un simple
sandwich ou dans une loge ou dans un
salon c'est pour tout le monde
d'accord on est venu on a intervenu sur
l'ensemble vraiment de de tous les
produits qui sont servi dans les stades
donc on va bien manger au stade ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle alors puisqu'on a
fini on va passer à présent au dessert
et c'est le pécher
mignon il est temps de passer au sucré
je crois que est déjà passé à la crème
caramel j'ai goûé mais vous avez raison
moi je suis d'accord un dessert
figurez-vous connu dès le Moyen Âge en
France plus tard cette friandise est app
des flahons dessert qui va ne cesser de
se populariser au fil des siècles
jusqu'à cette version moderne avec du
caramel sur le dessus préparé et cuite
auamarie mentionné pour la première fois
dans un livre la cuisine provençale
publié en 1897 alors j'ai une question
Yve est-ce que c'est bien votre dessert
préféré ou alors un message subliminal
envoyé au ridbyman soyez des crèmes dans
la vie mais sur le terrain allez-y
mettez des caramels aux adversaires non
c'est mon dessin préféré les crèmes
j'adore les crèmes pris et d'ailleurs
elle est très très bonne parce qu'elle
est très équilibrée elle est très peu
collée avec des œufs donc elle garde ce
côté très soyeux c'est une très belle
réussite digne de la bistronomie digne
de la bistronomie mais digne de la
gastronomie aussi ah pardon je vais me
fâcher de la cuisine bourgeoise aussi
parce que mais non une superbe crème
caramel servie en fin d'un repas ça peut
être un dessert merveilleux ou alors
vous vous la faites comment vot crème
caramel alors moi je fais je fais pas
mieux que ça pour être franc la seule
chose que je fais je m'amuse à mettre
des feuilles de laurier dans le lait ah
oui quand je fais bouillir mon lait
j'infuse des feuilles de laurier dedans
et je trouve que ça ça amène un twist
très agréable totalement différent parce
que le laurier en pâtisserie on
l'utilise très très peu c'est plus
souvent avec le poisson et j'adore cette
ce côté du laurier qui qui amène
beaucoup de fraîcheur et peut-être une
âme supplémentaire que que je votre
astuce la feuille de laurier dans la
crème Caramelle je vais essayer oui
juste un fusil dans Leit pour moi très
agréable est-ce qu'on peut être aussi
bon en salé qu'enucré est-ce que vous
êtes aussi à l'aise quand vous faites de
la pâtisserie que quand vous faites un
un plat euh oui je suis aussi à l'aise
en sucré qu'en qu'en salé mais ma
spécialité ça reste quand même le le le
salé et on dit voilà nous on fait des
des desserts de cuisinier voilà c'est là
la crème caramel c'est vraiment
typiquement un dessert de cuisinier
voilà je vais pas concurrencer un
Christophe michalac ou ou un ou ou ou un
feldaer ou un Pier armé voilà qui sont
des pures pâtissiers et qui font des des
desserts voilà technique et pratiquement
aujourd'hui c'est tous des des œuvres
d'art nous les cuisiniers voilà on va
l'ESS les dessert de de cuisinier c'est
c'est la c'est la crème caramel c'est
c'est une mousse au chocolat c'est une
crêpe suzette c'est un soufflet chaud
grandmnier une nom norvégienne une tarte
fine aux pommes on est plus sur des
classiques de cuisinier que pas la
pâtisserie aujourd'hui qu'on voit qui
une pâtisserie maintenant devenue très
artistique avec beaucoup de technique
alors il y a le duel Beatles
RollingStone il y a aussi le duel crème
caramel crème brûlée vous êtes plutôt
crème brûlé ou crème caramel non je je
mettrai pas de duel parce que les deux
sont très très bonnes car elles sont
bien réalist faut choisir
euh crème caramel pourquoi il faut
toujours
choisirah votre choix là vous avez chois
crème Caram vous savez faites des menus
vous savez bien que vos clients sont
obligés de choisir vous faites du c'est
vous qui proposez le choix les
restaurate c'est moi c'est moi qui
choisit donc par exemple je vais faire
je vais faire crème caramel l'hiver et
je vais faire crème brûlée l'été
pourquoi parce que la crème caramel
voilà je trouve que c'est c'est plus
rond c'est plus chaleureux et que le
côté crème brûlée voilà c'est un genre
de de Cha frroid qui un peu plus qui est
différent c'est de choses différentes
mais c'est deux choses quand elles sont
bien faites elles sont exceptionnelles
et merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
politique à table sur LCP